[Music]
foreign
omer davidi be hero welcome
thank you thank you thank you for having
me of course i love the poster behind
you
uh yeah we're trying to uh comply with
the innovative approach of upwest
i love it okay so you're saving bees
around the world
and you took me on a field trip to to
see a
to see a an acre of land what was it how
was it
oh my god it was literally one of the
one of the most fun days i've had in
years
and i'm scared shitless of bees i mean i
see a beer
i was just walking benny outside and i
saw a bee and i ran with him to the
other side
i i even thought of leaving him here
leaving him there so the bee
gets occupied with him and not with me
yeah i think now with this uh corona
thing even
people that are afraid from bees would
prefer to go and
inspect some hives instead of staying at
home so uh you got a chance to do it
before this lockdown
uh yeah yeah it's quite exciting i i
must agree
no no i mean just getting there and just
to pin the picture
forever doesn't know be hero you get to
a field
and you see a big crate a big wooden
crate
and you see and you know that inside
there's like what thousand bees that how
many bees are in one
hundreds of thousands yeah approximately
forty thousand bees in that in one box
forty thousand bees in a hive
yeah you see how crowded it is okay good
thing you didn't tell me that before
because i wouldn't have gone on the
field
and then you open the lid and you
realize that there's this
white plastic sensor that collects all
these parameters on the bees
so you can sense the health status of
the bees and the quality of pollination
and then you realize that you actually
have a high-tech beehive
and that is both optimizing for the
farmers but it's also saving bees so
tell me a little bit about what is this
high-tech beehive and how is it actually
helping farmers and bees
um yes so i think uh you know every time
we talk about bees the first
things that comes to mind is the honey
yeah we
most of all take honey and this is one
of the
the things that bees produce uh but what
most of us doesn't know
is that i mean you've mentioned the
farmer and this is something i didn't
know at the beginning is that those bees
are
actually being used to pollinate 70
of everything we eat and
i know uh corona is a bit new for us but
uh the bees has been facing something
similar
for the last 10 years uh what led the
mortality rates among the economies to
uh become over 40 percent and those
mortality
rates affect um the population
like the wild bee population what does
that mean 40
to be mortality uh that if you are a
beekeeper
and you grow bees in those little boxes
that you sometimes see in the fields
uh half of those boxes uh will die
it means that the queen in those hives
will die the bees will not have a reason
to live
without the queen they will not have new
generation to replace them
once they die and in a very short period
of time the colony just collapses
and now you have an empty box that you
will have to spend a lot of resources to
revive
entering the next season or the next
year and you lot you've just lost
pollination
from that box for your current season
right yeah and we're talking about
millions of flowers so uh
evolution walk together on the on the
flowers and on the bees
or insects overall to make them very
efficient
a single bee colony can pollinate
millions of flowers a day
and if you lose this hive during the
pollination season during the blooming
season
you just lost the ability to uh to
pollinate those millions of flowers that
will not turn out to be
food okay so now that you're explaining
this it
it's obvious why it's a huge problem and
also huge
financial potential for whoever manages
to to salvage
these 40 of of beehives why
why why are people not doing this why
isn't there's so much crazy competition
why isn't google and facebook going and
trying to solve this as well if it's
such a big opportunity i guess they have
their own problems to do with first but
uh
i think i think it involves with a lot
of uh domain expertise in this field
and a lot of work i mean uh dealing with
biological
super organism is in hive involves the
collection of a lot of data
we are focusing on two aspects of this
problem one is
how can we decrease immortality and
improve the quality of the hive
i mean how can we provide beekeepers
with better tools to maintain stronger
colonies that pollinates better
uh and the second one is how to actually
optimize the process of pollination how
can we maximize the amount of flowers
that every hive is
is visiting and and you know
two and a half three years ago there was
nothing done in this field
uh not a lot of data very sophisticated
experiments and small amount of hives
and what we've decided to do from from
day one is just to collect massive
amount of information
and we've been doing this for the last
two and a half years having
tens of thousands of hives uh uploading
data
several times a day and and this is
where we got the opportunity to
to actually do something we started to
see some companies i'm telling this
market
there's uh some very interesting
opportunities there um
and and competition is a good thing uh
maybe not competing against google but
competition is a good thing no so you
so you do have the largest data set on
b's in the world right and you can you
keep growing and increasing and i think
it's genius that
that first thing out of the box you
realize that yeah this is a data game
and at the end even if that you don't
have you know all the features ready and
all the products ready and you don't
have
thousands of customers even just getting
yourself out there and being able to
collect this data for your own
learning that i think that's incredible
and um
so but you don't you're not coming from
this space and you're talking you're
saying the domain expertise is critical
and you have a fascinating co-founder
who's helping you with that right
uh yeah so i'm i'm actually coming from
the the tech side of things
dealt a lot with cyber security so i do
have experience in analyzing data and
looking for patterns but
less on the beekeeping side one of my
co-founders is izzy thai
uh he's a second generation commercial
beekeeper
his family owns the largest b firm in
israel
and he was the one to um guide me
through this
thing uh it's quite exciting as you saw
as a as a tech person yourself
you know opening a hive um is that
something that you don't get to see
every day and i think that the
passion around it and the same questions
that we've raised about you know
how humanity is going to handle the
immortality situation and so on
uh led us to investigate it a little bit
further
and and this is how it all started now i
know in when i was working on be hero
for one of my projects at stanford one
of the things that
uh that came apparent one of the
competitors
uh they they had this technology also
that is able to send stuff within a
beehive but when
in an experiment while it registered
that the bee
hive is healthy you actually open the
box and and it's dead
uh and i and i know and and just when
you're saying these things
it it really resonates on this this this
distance between what a tech person
codes and what happens in real life and
it's one thing to go and think that it
and sit behind a computer and analyze
these parameters and sensors it's
another thing to go and physically open
a box of 50 000 bees
and see whether what you did make sense
and having that domain expertise that
itai has
and and it was just fascinating to learn
how to even spot the queen
and how can you tell what's happening in
there and it was really really great so
what what what happened before be hero
talk to me a little bit about that
what happened before be hero first of
all we didn't know anything about the
corona so our life was a little bit more
simple
uh but besides this uh i've had the
opportunity to work on uh
three interesting projects uh and i also
work with
uh the israeli cyber center on some
interesting projects as well
um so i i faced uh you know selling
companies
in the past i faced closing company uh
one in the past
uh so i think i've seen both
sides of the coin i would say um i think
i'm always looking
for fields where uh the technology that
i feel comfortable with
and i'm we're not talking about you know
uh um
space science or things that are like
super deep deep tech
uh that takes years of deployment and
development
can be useful in order to optimize and
you know i've done it in the energy
space in aquaculture in retail
and i think you know seeing now
the the farming industry and the
beekeeping industry is a new challenge
is
is very fascinating and uh we've managed
to build a very good
team that i'm very happy with how do you
deal with this difference that you're
your tech expert
italia is a beekeeper expert but you
know it's
is do you find it difficult to
communicate and set kpis and milestones
as a company
because of that um i think it becomes
hard when it
needs to be a lot of time in the office
he's more of a field type of guy he has
to be out there
um i think and this is something that
we're still facing i mean now we are
more people and we have you know a
phd in biology and electrical
engineering and different kind of
people to help and improve the
algorithms
i think there is a gap between the
understanding of
expert beekeepers i would say with
technologies like machine learning
and on the developers side they have a
lot of
um experience in machine learning but
they know nothing about these so yeah
for example when you see an outlier
coming from the data you don't have the
the knowledge in order to analyze it um
and and
the the main challenge that i see over
there is is
i can call it miscommunication i don't
know if it's really a miscommunication
but
some of the assumptions that the
biologists of the beekeeper make
uh handling the the questions that you
know on the table in terms of algorithms
can affect the way we're going to
progress and i think
simplicity is the answer so we are
trying to
um analyze everything in a very simple
way so the developers do not become an
experts in biology but they do
understand what they need to
in order to improve and also on the
biological side you do need to have the
context
of what we are trying to do on the
development side
otherwise uh you know even designing an
experiment to to classify a new problem
yeah um just might not work uh so i do
see some challenges in this i think
we're getting better and better
um and um and yeah it would be
interesting to see how far can we go
with it we are exploring some
additional things um for future like as
a future
um vision we have uh so it's
quite fascinating yeah i already shared
with you how excited i got when i when i
learned about be heroes so much that i
wanted
to dive deeper within at stanford and i
already told you that one day i want to
be
a b hero myself um and and i see this
going
so far i i see this going uh
really really really far um and you know
i i think really
you mentioned when when i came on the
field trip you mentioned you just you
can't understand
without being there you can't sit in an
office and
and think about bees and think about the
farmers without actually being in the
field and and
seeing what a beekeeper does and how
easy it is
to and how easy it is for a beekeeper to
lose a colony
and to lose pollination and you
literally see thousands of trees around
you and you can imagine what happens
what have if you can just optimize
pollination a little bit more
and one of the things that excite me
most about what you're doing is that
that you're actually changing the whole
the whole business model of the
interaction between farmers and
beekeepers where farmers instead of
paying
for a paying by beehive they're paying
per acre of pollination
which means for you that the more you
optimize your mathematical models
the less hives you need to put to
provide the same pollination
and this win-win situation to me that's
very exciting because it's really pure
win-win
you're not going at the expense at the
expense of them
and so what's happening now with corona
uh
everybody's at home a lot of industries
are thinking
is the agriculture field thinking
uh so i think it's it's a little bit
early to say i mean we
as long as we have enough people that
you know needs food
um we we need to have farmers producing
those uh
ingredients and food so i don't think it
will impact
this industry the way it might impact
other industries i mean
if we're talking about travel industries
and other areas will
um going to get most of the impact they
get
i think that also when you look at the
farming industry
like we handle this crisis by cutting
everything that is not needed because we
don't know how much runway we're going
to need
and when the market's going to be
stabilized again and so on
uh every other business is doing this as
well
so for example farmers
would dedicate less money for innovation
i'm sure
i mean we don't see it yet but i'm sure
it's going to happen
and you know i'm being able to meet
face-to-face definitely affects the
acquisition cycles that we had we need
to find different ways to communicate
right um so what we do now we focus
mostly on those
customers we already have uh trying to
expand
working with them and we'll have to
figure out how it's gonna
how it's gonna work i think in the next
two three months
this crisis gonna affect the most and
then at some point people will have to
find ways
to continue working just because the the
economy will not enable
this to continue too much so it
definitely affects the market
uh i think um i'm lucky first of all to
be in this space
which i think will not get uh will not
absorb most of the impact
and secondly you know it's a question of
runway if
i were to raise funds now i think it
would have been
very complicated very hard valuation
will probably drop down
which makes it harder to you know get a
lot of money because you cannot dilute
too much it doesn't look good you know
for future rounds of course so i think
it's
it's it's also luck that you know we
we've closed the round couple of months
ago and we have enough runway to go
through this thing
it doesn't mean that we don't do any
cuts but we just mean that um
we're trying to understand where where
we're going with it
um we're based in the us which is our
main market
which is good i guess for companies
based in israel
they do not have good enough uh um
position in in the in the main market
now it's becoming more challenging
because the
ability to fly uh drop down
significantly
um so yeah i think it's uh
it's it's a crazy uh thing we are facing
uh and and i'm pretty confident we can
go over over it um yeah you know i was i
was speaking to
shuli and uh shirley galilee and
one of the one of the investors and and
be hero and one of the things that she's
uh she says about herself she's an
optimist and she's looking at this time
on
on how you can sit back and reflect also
on what's happening
and really assess the value that you're
creating and how how can you spark
innovation
from this time uh so i i
i'm definitely trying to take it too
hard and take also my own time to do
these assessments
omer before we before we finish um
and you have to go back to saving uh
millions or billions of bees
i need three words about you
that describe you three words
um that's challenging to prepare me for
this
that's the point um everybody's gonna
hate me after these interviews i'm
putting everybody on the spot
maybe i should stop um i would go with
uh
passionate nice um
um that stuff
um
positive yes
curious i love it passionate
positive curious yeah i think that's the
only reason to deal with
entrepreneurship
because realistically it makes no sense
so i think i think yeah i didn't have
enough time to think of it but
i think i love them no i i i love them
and i completely agree
so if corona comes back next year
like many say they do we're going to do
this again and i want to see if the if
your three words are the same um perfect
and uh we we will be happy to have you
uh before the next crisis that would be
fantastic
thank you so so much and good luck with
all the bees
thank you so much and take care through
this crazy time
you